Частина села далі - вона там вся зрешечена. Сорок "приходів" було.
- Коли? - Вчора.
Реактивна артилерія, танки стріляють, протитанкові ракети, гармати.
Я сам не кадровий офіцер. Я свого часу навчався в університеті, закінчив військову кафедру.
- А у цивільному житті Ви хто? - Я головний інженер машинобудівного підприємства у місті Дружківка.
Серед тих, хто тримає фронт на Донеччині - чимало місцевих. Жителі Дружківки, Бахмута, Торецька та інших міст на Донбасі
як ніхто знають, що насправді несуть "захист" та "звільнення" у розумінні Путіна.
Робітник з Краматорська Олексій зі псевдо "Папай" першого ж дня пішов на війну добровольцем -
попри солідний вік та інвалідність. У перервах між обстрілами удосконалює свою українську.
Тут ділове мовлення, вислови різні. Я стараюсь. Коли ти розмовляєш суржиком, то ти їх не вживаєш. Розумієте?
Нема мовної практики, нема з ким практикувати мову.
- А звідки Ви?
Краматорськ.
- Путін каже, що треба захищати російськомовних. А Ви тут вивчаєте українське ділове мовлення.
Ні, ні. Ніхто такого навіть не думає, що Путін когось там захищає. Таких людей взагалі нема. Я не зустрічав у Краматорську.
Ніхто нікого не змушує, не примушує. Мене ж ніхто не примушував. Я ж теж розмовляв суржиком.
Але коли почались ці події, то треба ж. Якщо ти в українській армії, то ти ж не можеш бути російськомовним.
Це моя принципова позиція. Я перейшов на українську і почав розмовляти українською.
- А за професією хто Ви?
Токар. Взагалі-то я токарем працював.
- Розкажіть, як Ви потрапили сюди?
Тільки почалося, 24 числа, я одразу, того ж дня, поїхав у військкомат, щоб взяти участь.
У мене травма. Я інвалід війни, так би мовити. У мене третя група. Але я пішов, тому що треба йти. Не чекати ж.
- В АТО воювали?
Да, да.
- Довго?
У 2019 році мене списали.
- Скільки років Вам?
62.
- 62 роки - це ж не призовний вік.
Ну й що? Що мені, сидіти вдома і чекати, поки ті уроди прийдуть? Ви розумієте?
Ні. Ворога не чекають вдома. Ворогу йдуть назустріч.
Так що вчимо мову - і слава Україні! Все добре!
Олександр з Дружківки - теж доброволець. На відміну від Олексія, військового досвіду не мав. Втім, мотивації колишньому фермеру не бракує.
У 2015 році я отримав повістку по мобілізації, але у військо я не потрапив по стану здоров'я - відстрочку дали на пів року.
Ну і скажу як є - трохи лячно було. Жити хочеться кожній людині.
Потім я протягом всіх цих років дивився наше українське телебачення і, коли я чув і бачив,
як молоді хлопці гинуть кожного дня, мені було соромно - я дорослий чоловік, а знаходжуся вдома.
І я завжди всім при спілкуванні казав: якщо потреба настане, я піду, незважаючи ні на що.
24 лютого "російські брати" вирішили нас "звільняти", і 25 лютого я поїхав у військкомат.
- Який у Вас позивний?
Єврей. У мене єврейське коріння. Мої предки з польських євреїв. Взагалі-то я українець, звісно, в першу чергу.
Але від своїх коренів відмовлятися нікому не треба.
- Цього Путін, мабуть, не зрозуміє. Що українець, єврей та ще й на Донбасі - і ось Ви воюєте проти них.
Я живу на своїй землі і мені Путін взагалі не указ. Ми зовсім різні з росіянами. Мені їхня допомога не потрібна.
Визволення від чого? Від життя? Від волі? Від свободи? Також мені не потрібно.
- А як цю війну припинити? Хтось каже, можливий якийсь компроміс?
Я Вам скажу так, як думаю я і, мабуть, більшість хлопців, які тримають в руках зброю, та й цивільні також.
Після всього цього лиха, що вони нам принесли, перемовин бути не може.
У нас єдиний шлях - знищити цю імперію. Вона не дасть нам спокою, перемовини ні до чого не приведуть.
Кумир Путіна Адольф Гітлер, якщо розібратися, він був "по жизні обіжений" - як і цей дурачок.